all right good morning everyone so on
foreign had such beautiful fullscreen
wide slides and I am just going to show
you everything three times so good
morning thank you for being here thank
you for the invitation
and as mr. bingo said I'm Dave Fogg just
some quick contact info and then I'll
put this up again at the end if any of
you would like to reach out and find me
okay come on
clicker let's go all right so we're
gonna be talking about simplicity today
and we're talking about it because it's
actually remarkably easy to make
anything complicated and so we don't
really think about putting effort into
this this is Rube Goldberg how many
people know him and his illustrations
yeah so Rube Goldberg is the guy that
did things like this how to open a
bottle of beer if you have no bottle
opener right so lots and lots of
unnecessary steps in order to accomplish
a relatively simple task so we don't
plan to make things complicated it just
sort of happens even when we are looking
it sort of happens we do however have to
work to simplify when we notice the
complication we realize it and then
we've got to do something about it so
we're going to be talking today about
how things become complicated and what
we can do about it and let's start off
by talking about products as systems now
you might be thinking what why are we
going to be talking about this because
we really have to be thinking about the
inner workings of things to understand
how we've made them complicated and
messy now systems have variables and
rules and we talk about them in terms of
rate of change and the state or the
condition at a moment in time and the
interactivity or the behavior of that
system and we can describe it on
essentially what are just four different
variables we can talk about how many
variables are there are we talking about
systems that have just a few variables
or systems that have a lot
variables oops don't want to spoil it we
have how many what are the types of
system rules is this a linear system or
is this a non-linear system we can talk
about whether or not we are able to
predict the future state of the behavior
of the system are they deterministic or
non-deterministic and we can talk about
whether or not the system actually can
adapt and change to changing conditions
around it
so is it adaptive or non adaptive this
is not usually a language we talk about
in design and product design very often
so humor me here you'll see how it all
starts to make sense now systems there
are different levels of complexity in
systems they can start off with the
really simple ones these are the ones
that we like because we understand them
it's a small number of variables at
simple rules we understand exactly
what's going on complicated things are
the things we often end up making and
then try to turn them into simple
systems they tend to have lots and lots
of variables but they still tend to have
fairly simple rules now we've got this
next group these are complex systems
they may have many variables but they're
dynamic they tend to change over time
and so they're not these really simple
predictable systems they're modifying
themselves and then the last class and
we'll also talk about this are the
chaotic systems these are the ones that
have the really strange behavior they
have a small number of variables but
they're almost completely unpredictable
for us and it seems like it should be a
predictable thing now we can also
visualize these and think about simple
two chaotic systems in terms of how they
might look right like the simple system
there's not much to it I know where I am
I know where I want to go there's one
path done but as the systems become
complicated and complex and chaotic
these illustrations sort of capture what
it feels like to be working with them
now today we're actually going to be
focusing just on the center - we're
gonna be talking about the complicated
systems which is something that we can
do something about and we're gonna be
talking about the complex system
which we may be able to simplify in some
cases so focusing on these two we might
be able to read to find them and if
we're talking about products as systems
we can say well instead of this
technical definition of how many
variables and what are the rule types I
like to think of them this way a
complicated system is a product that has
many many parts it's got lots of moving
pieces whereas a complex system is like
a system of systems it's a product of
many products and so you can see where
the complexity begins to come from all
right now what about the chaotic systems
we said there's simple ones we're not
going to do anything about those we're
going to focus on complicated and
complex but the chaotic ones
why don't we bother talking about these
so we can describe chaotic systems as in
they seem like they're impossibly
complex because their behavior is
unpredictable but it actually turns out
that mathematically there's almost
always a remarkably few number of actual
variables involved and so there's this
paradox of it looks like it should be
simple but I can't quite figure it out
now the first real chaotic system that
we began to study and this was only 50
60 years ago was the weather so you know
when you look at the weather forecast
you can see that it's just seven to ten
days out and then beyond that it's
pretty much just uh I don't know
guess right air temperature water
something will happen why can't we
predict the weather so far out we've got
satellites we've got weather stations
all over the place we have more data
than we know what to do with
we have supercomputers that are trying
to do this and yet we still have no
better accuracy beyond about ten days so
in the past 60 years we have gone from
three to five to ten days of
predictability seems like we should be
doing better
well that's because weather is actually
a chaotic system those three equations
those three simple differential
Asians describe atmospheric convection
and that little graphic beside them is
what's called a strange attractor what
that strange attractor tells us is that
I know that the weather is going to be
within some limits they're called the
bounds of the system it's never going to
be 500 degrees outside and we're never
going to get 30 meters of rain in a day
that's just not going to happen right
but we never know where the weather is
going to be within those boundaries
somewhere in that graph is tomorrow's
weather and we just don't know exactly
where it is and these laws are universal
they apply all over the place this is
the South Pole of Jupiter
we sent a spacecraft out to flyby and
take these photos and you see the same
patterns in the clouds of a gas giant as
you do in the clouds of the earth so
these laws apply everywhere now we can't
simplify chaos that's why we're not
going to pay attention to it okay we
can't make chaotic systems predictable
when we have a truly chaotic system that
we're working with we just have to live
with it so we recognize it or like yeah
mathematically this is awesome but from
a design perspective yeah not much we
can do alright so we're gonna focus on
what we can work on complicated and
complex systems and sometimes the
complex systems are naturally complex
it's just the way they are my favorite
traffic circle in the world right it
works there might be other solutions to
it right but it is certainly a complex
experience now I call this one complex
because it is essentially a system of
systems if you were to break it down and
think about it there is a roadway system
there is a car which is a system and
there are pedestrians which each
individual person is a system and the
people interact with one another who
interact with the cars who interact with
the physical structure of the
roadway so it's a system of systems that
exhibits very complex behavior now to
draw a quick analogy for you it's like
people on the internet people
interacting with one another have mobile
devices which is another system who
interact with web-based services and
applications which is another system so
when we talk about user experience
design we're talking about systems and
systems and systems so many of these are
naturally complex right so we narrow
ourselves a bit more and we say well if
they're naturally complex there might be
something we can do with it but the
complicated ones these are things that
we made bad and these are the things
that we can simplify now I have another
I like pruning trees yes I like the the
aesthetics of the structure of the tree
I also have another hobby and that is as
I travel around the world I take
photographs of the payment kiosks in
parking garages these kiosks are
uniformly terrible experiences all
around the world right I have become
trapped in parking garages because I
can't figure out how to pay to get out
and oftentimes you can't find another
human to actually help you you know you
have a problem with your design if total
strangers write instructions for other
total strangers and tape them on to the
machines right so this is something that
doesn't need to be complicated it is
something which was made complicated and
so this is just a fantastic example of
opportunities to simplify so how did
those parking garage kiosks how did some
of the products you use on a daily basis
actually become complicated
well if we take a step back at our own
design process this is what we often see
in the beginning we have a project and
we're like I got this I understand it I
know how hard this is gonna be I know
what we need to it
Eve we know what we're going to do to
get there we even provide estimates of
time and effort and cost to clients to
say I'll give you a finished product in
n days for this number of dollars and
then we start right and not shortly
after we start someone in the group or
from the client says oh by the way there
are these other requirements or there
are some other constraints or there's a
couple things we forgot to talk about
and some information that you didn't
have and the complication of the product
begins to creep upward shortly after
that someone during one of the ideation
sessions and sketching on a whiteboard
says dude it would be so cool if write
and another feature goes on the list and
so now there's more to do in the same
time and with the same budget and then
we actually start prototyping and
testing things and the client sees it
and the creative director sees it and
they go this is very nice it looks good
but I think it should and it needs a
little more and there's still this other
thing we haven't done right and so we
get a little more creep and a little
more change and then we start building
it and somewhere an engineer says this
is a really nice idea but you know the
system doesn't support it or this is a
really nice idea but it's actually
difficult to implement how important is
it can we get rid of it right and you're
like no no that's like the whole purpose
of the thing and so then they figure out
how to work around what the constraints
are and eventually sometime a few weeks
after the original deadline we end up at
a point where we call feature complete
and we're like oh thank god it's done
get it out the door launch it let's keep
going right but there's a problem here
and that is that we have designed and
iterated ourselves to the point of
maximum complication
yes it does all of the things on the
checklist and it may do some of them
well and it may do some of them poorly
but the overall experience is one that
just feels complicated it's not as
simple as that concept we had on day one
so what are we going to do at this point
in time
right how did we get there well we just
talked about some of the things that
happen but if we really break it down we
start to talk about things like well
maybe we rushed some of the design or
maybe product management wasn't really
tracking the scope and the cost and the
number of requests and change orders
that were being tracked maybe there were
technical issues and the system can't
support that or we couldn't build it in
the way that we thought we were going to
and maybe there were simply constraints
and requirements you can't do this
because there's gdpr
you can't do this because there is a
technical constraint you can't do this
because we actually don't have that
piece of data and so we can't make that
prediction for you right and all of
these things surface and then we have to
figure out how to work around them and
every time you work around something you
make complication happen right it
happens gradually but eventually we get
to a point where the light bulb goes off
on everyone on the team goes that's not
very good right and so they all look at
each other and they say the same thing
let's make it simpler let's let's get
rid of all this mess let's let's fix
this right now we'll pause for a moment
and we'll say not everything should be
simple right I'm not really confident
that we should have a simple one-click
nuclear launch mechanism there's a
reason why it takes multiple people and
codes and keys and simultaneous timing
because this is the kind of thing you
don't want to do accidentally right
nodding off at work
so too much simplicity can sometimes be
bad sometimes we take it too far it's
just a little story do you recognize
these you know what these are
yeah these are from Amazon these are the
one-click buttons from Amazon so that
when you're sitting on the toilet and
you have no toilet paper click and
Amazon sends you toilet paper right or
when you're taking out the trash and you
have no trash bags
click Amazon sends you trash bags it's a
really nice idea for like the daily
staples makes it really really simple
but when might simplicity not be one of
our goals when might we want people to
take time to interact and understand
something if it's too fast and too easy
some types of problems can occur we
maybe make mistakes
I didn't quite know what was going on
but it was just so easy to click forward
and then all of a sudden I own 300
pounds of dog food some inadvertent
interactions may be irreversible what do
you mean I can't return 300 pounds of
dog food people may not adequately
understand the actions of their are
their their actions and the outcomes but
I don't have a dog people may not learn
how to use the system this is easy I
don't need to put any thought into it I
don't actually have to think about what
I'm doing click click click done
products may be easy to misuse or
subvert or mislead so there's the evil
intention that may happen products may
have unintended consequences right
something might happen in the future
based on interactions that are too easy
to perform sounds like a great idea
doesn't it
I mean come on click beer me but what if
you're an unsupervised ten-year-old or
what if you are recovering alcoholic
where what are the unintended
consequences of having a one-click beer
delivery button right so have we made it
too simple in some situations so some
difficulty some complexity sometimes
slowing people down can be a good thing
the financial services industry is
highly regulated and one of the things
in those regulations is essentially
slowing of people down giving them lots
and lots of information so that they can
make a reasoned decision about where
they can invest their money or where
they should invest their money and so
would you really want one-click stock
purchasing and then to have someone
maliciously promote a whole bunch of
terrible stocks to you this sounds great
buy another great one buy and how much
money might you lose so they put these
little fiction moments into the
experience to say here's the data here's
what's going on here's what's to cut to
consider they make the buying process
multiple steps so that you understand
exactly how much money you're going to
spend and that it is in effect an
irreversible action and then at the very
end they show you all of the choices
you've made and ask you once more are
you really sure yes right so it takes
probably twelve steps more than
theoretically it could to buy something
because you have to slow down to think
about what you are purchasing so the
goals for simplicity have to be balanced
against what are some of the things that
might go wrong how much friction is
ideal how much ease is ideal and we
could really probably identify four goal
or sorry three goals for ourselves about
simplicity we can talk about what can we
reduce right how do I make it easier how
do I get rid of waste how do I reduce
errors
how do I reduce stress we can talk about
improving the experience enhancements to
meaningfulness and the quality of the
product we can even talk about
individual well-being I feel good about
this and we can talk about helping
people how do they learn how do they
share how do they make better decisions
so if we think about balancing the ease
and the friction we might use these
principles or these goals to guide us in
the end what we want is something that
helps people feel effective intelligent
and confident right I can do this I
understand this and I am sure that this
is what I want to do so I'm not sure if
Einstein actually said this or not but
it's widely attributed to him make
everything as simple as possible but no
simpler
it's the caution don't go too far don't
take too much away
don't make it too slippery maybe some
friction helps now if you recognize what
this figure is stay quiet
how many of you don't recognize this
figure anyone in the room not recognize
this figure no one okay just one boy
that was your brave one hand all right
that's Damien Hirst's dot image of Walt
Disney's Mickey Mouse it's a graphic
literally a graphic illustration of
simplification right the problem with
this level of simplification if for an
artist this seems like a brilliant thing
but if you're doing something in terms
of product design the problem behind
this is if you don't already know who
Mickey Mouse is you would have no idea
what Hurst's painting portrayed
that simplification requires so much
prior knowledge and experience and if
you have a product that is new to the
world and going out there for the first
time no one has that prior knowledge and
that prior experience and if you
oversimplify people may have no idea
what it is how to use it or what to do
so even though we're talking about
simplification we caution you about not
oversimplifying so we follow the law of
parsimony sometimes also called Occam's
razor all things being equal the simpler
solution is the better solution all
right so we find ourselves at the peak
of this complication curve we've worked
ourselves up to maximum complication
what do we do from here what are some of
our options we need to get this this
number the score this level down there's
a few methods that we can apply but the
amount of effort that we put into it
really determines how much we're able to
simplify if we pretty much do nothing
and we just polish up the edges and ship
the product as is we can get rid of a
little of that complication but we're
still going to send out a complicated
product it just might be a slightly
prettier complicated product but if we
put a little bit more time and energy
into iteration sorry a sufficiently
motivated person on the other hand is
going to tolerate an inordinate amount
of poop icon what this means is that if
you are the only product in a space and
people need your service they will use
it even if it's crappy most of us
however are not in that situation we
don't have a loan product in the space
there is competition and so we need to
make the product better if I really
really really have to get something done
I will tolerate really really bad
experiences how many of you have done
that on the web
you've hated every step you took through
the entire process and you finished it
despite that product yes almost every
single hand goes up right because you
felt you had no choice that's a
protected privileged position for a
product that's not what we can take
advantage of so we want to put more
effort into our simplification right we
want to work a little bit harder to make
this product better so if we put just a
little more time and effort into it we
can do things like polish up the content
and polish up the visual design
maybe smooth out some of the motion and
the interactivity and refine a gestural
interaction system so we can make the
product more clear for people it's
amazing what a professional rewrite can
do to simplify a product even if you
change nothing about the architecture
and the interactions but if we keep
working a little bit more and we start
thinking about those interactions and we
think about the architecture of the
product ah now we can start to rearrange
things to make them a little bit easier
to understand and act upon maybe we take
a few steps out of the checkout process
so instead of buying scented candles in
seven steps now I can buy my favorite
scented candles in three steps and it
feels faster right so that's just a
structural change but if we really put
more time and effort into it we can
reach sort of our maximum simplification
and that is we have the opportunity to
really start looking critically at how
people move through your product and
service and sometimes not even just your
product but what are they doing before
during and after an experience with your
product this usually requires much
larger changes to the product this
requires us sometimes to change our
principles and to change the
architecture and sometimes even change
the core functionality but if we make it
easier for people to flow through an
experience that really is what people
say makes people say wow this was easy
this was simple this was pleasant or
d'lai
unfortunately most teams don't spend the
extra time to get much farther beyond
the as is state but we do have some
techniques that we can apply however the
client usually has this response when
you say feature complete we're finished
but we're still need to go back through
and iterate and make this better even
though everything is working now and the
client goes wait what you said it's all
working why aren't we launching this
right do we really need to keep
designing something after we finished
designing it mm-hmm yes and why because
this is where the simplification happens
not on the way up but on the way down
now you know the the phrase you can't
see the forest for the trees
simplification and product
simplification is one of those things
where we think to ourselves am I looking
at a forest or am i seeing the
individual trees and what should I be
focused on we become so close to our
products over the process of design that
we become blind to the complication we
have actually put into that product
ourselves it makes sense to us because
we created it it's other people who are
going to use it and so we can't just
easily step back and look at our own
product objectively so we have to remind
ourselves to do that we have to apply
some techniques to do that and we have
to do some research and testing to
figure out what's working and what isn't
so what are some signs if we're blind to
the complication we put into our own
products what might we look for that
would be an indicator that maybe we've
added to some complication in this
process right well did you design
something because you needed it or did
you design something because there's a
well-documented user need for it so
designing for yourself is often a really
good way to make something complicated
for other people
did you lead with technology did someone
in your company say look at this really
cool thing we can do let's put it into
our product and did you ask the question
do people need us to do that or did you
go wow that's so cool no one else does
this let's add it right Wow maybe you're
a solution looking for a problem
did you map the product structure to
your organizational structure right now
I have to happily say this one seems to
be decreasing in frequency in my
experience 10 years ago or so I was
working in financial services and it was
super common for banks and investment
houses to actually take their internal
organizational structure and map it
directly to their website this is the
investment group this is the banking
group this is the research group and
this is the retirement group that's fine
if you are your own user and client but
the end consumer does not think about
managing their money in terms of your
organizational structure so if your
product is mapped to your company
structure chances are it is not mapped
to what the end user actually has to do
product by consensus where you do
everything in the product only after
everyone on the team goes right and so
then you end up being nice to one
another and you end up adding things
that don't have to be there and you end
up agreeing to compromises that might
actually be bad maybe you've made
assumptions and the problem with
assumptions at the beginning of a
project is that if you don't test them
or think critically about them they have
this curious way of becoming fact over
the course of the project that the
assumption on day one is just something
at the end of the project that everyone
knows to be true even though no one ever
actually checked that fact
right so when you make assumptions and
then you don't test them you've probably
made something complicated maybe you
copy other solutions right I think
that's what happened with parking garage
kiosks there's like half a dozen
companies that make them but they're all
sort of bad in the same way and it's
like really is is there like some
industrial spy who is making money by by
propagating bad ideas from company to
company in InDesign we call these anti
patterns right now we know what a
pattern is right a pattern is a known
solution to a known problem an
anti-pattern is when you take that known
solution but you apply it to the wrong
problem so you use a perfectly good
design pattern in the wrong situation or
the wrong circumstance and although it
looks on the surface like it's a good
idea it actually isn't and it adds
complication in direct action one of my
favorites anytime you ask a person to do
something here in order to get an
outcome or an interaction there you've
introduced complication because now the
human has to do work here then do
something here and they have to remember
what happened here to then go do
something here and so if you bring these
things together if you treat humans as
if they are magnetic and you always take
to them the information and
functionality that they need at that
moment it's going to be a far simpler
experience if we say things like make it
a setting make it a choice let the user
decide right that's essentially
abdicating your responsibility as a
designer to create a good product you
are not willing to make a product
decision and so the answer is I don't
know let the person do it and so you
then have lists and lists of things that
people have to choose from and the more
people have to choose and change the set
and make decisions the harder it is the
less enjoyable it is and the more
complicated it is right so if you say
let the user decide that's a trigger
word if you hear feedback from people
messy confusing I mean how could you not
miss this one right if York if your user
in research says this is complicated
they've just told you you have a problem
right this is the most obvious thing to
listen for the trick here is you
actually have to do the research you
actually have to put it in front of
people and get them to provide you this
feedback what if the team is saying it
would be nice to have right we said that
is one of the things on the ramp up to
the feature complete state so anytime
you say it would be nice to have
probably means you thought of something
that wasn't originally requirement and
has not been validated as an actual user
need you just think there's something
clever or cute or shiny about it right
and so it gets added to the list if you
try to be everything to everyone you end
up being nothing to everyone right for
those of you Simpsons fans this is the
Homer mobile and I don't know if you
remember this episode or not
yes homers long-lost brother who happens
to be a very successful automotive maker
finds him hires him to make the car for
the everyman which is an abomination in
the automotive world and it costs eighty
five thousand dollars so it's not even
affordable to everyone right so it's
it's nothing to everyone and then my
favorite very end here I was just
packing for a weekend trip right so if
you say let's put it in just in case
you've probably added things that don't
need to be there right just in case
means you do really know what situations
or circumstances may arise all right so
we've got all these signals these are
things we can look for these are things
we can listen for so what do we do about
this unnecessary complication please
give us methods so there are some
foundational design methods we can apply
I'm not gonna go into great detail on
any of these because they should all be
familiar to any designer any UX designer
in here your methodology right is
identified define and frame be really
really clear about what you're trying to
solve and keep yourself scoped to those
problems use user centered design
methods mental models and flows and maps
and diagrams don't go straight to
wireframes or mocks right that's not
where you solve the problem start
thinking a little bit sooner apply
critical thinking skills this is
probably one of the most important
things for a UX designer is to have
really strong critical thinking skills
and then of course the standard iterate
the hell out of it right you don't get
it right the first time around we keep
working on it to improve it
now I like to talk about the iterative
approach in a little bit more detail
because when we're working on product
design there's essentially three levels
three core iterations we go through the
first is when we talk about the
structure of the product itself what are
all of the parts what's the content the
functionality the services how are they
interrelated how is the structure of
this thing going to meet a known and
documented list of user needs when we
understand all the pieces that we need
now we start to think about how are they
connected and how are people going to
use them in sequence how are they going
to move through this product or service
and only once we know what the bits are
and how they are connected and how
people are going to move through them do
we shift our attention to creating an
interface because now we know exactly
what needs to happen in every step and
what needs to be shown on every page and
what information needs to be presented
in which format we've already thought
about the foundation of the problems now
we're just putting the interface on top
of it and through all of this
the decisions that we make at an earlier
phase influence the decisions we make at
a subsequent phase so as I'm thinking
about the structure that is going to
influence the flow and as I think about
the flow it's gonna influence the
interface and even some of the
structural decisions are going to have
an influence on the interface but we've
got to test all of these things so we
conduct research that runs through the
entire thing we have the right parts do
we have the right connections do we have
the right display mechanism and we very
often learn things that cause us to go
back and make changes at one of these
earlier levels so it's not just the UX
diagram of one big circle right were you
ID eight and then you design and you
prototype and you build and you launch
and you measure and then you ID eight
that big circle is nice because it tells
you sort of what's happening at the
product level but our design process is
actually iterations within iterations
within iterations it's almost like a
complex system it's a system of systems
right all these connected parts so here
are some methods that we can use to
simplify now these actually come out of
you don't need to be embarrassed by your
answers here how many people have an
Android phone okay Oh a nice number
thank you okay I'm on the Android team
so how many of you have the the Android
PI enjoy P and the pixel three okay some
of you which means you don't have pixel
phones if you don't have Android Pi so
you're waiting for your manufacturer or
carrier to slowly glacially roll it out
to you sorry about that
for Android Pi we had a simplicity goal
let's make the user experience simpler
for using a pixel phone and so we have
these mechanisms that we set up for
ourselves now subtract is the first
method for simplification that almost
every single team goes to we often just
equate or end unfortunately conflate
simplification with subtraction get rid
of all the excess stuff
right that's just one mechanism right
get all get rid of all the superfluous
fine but there's other things we can do
we can consolidate sometimes we have too
many little pieces and those little
pieces could actually be combined into
one thing instead and so instead of
having 17 things maybe we've only got
eight we just reduced the number by
consolidating we're actually not losing
any content or functionality we're just
combining stuff maybe we redistribute
maybe it's complex and complicated
simply because we've got things in the
wrong place maybe we need to take
something which is big and confusing and
break it down into smaller pieces each
of which is more meaningful maybe we
just haven't set the proper priorities
when you look at the screen and there's
12 options and you don't know which is
the one most relevant and important
because everything you can do has equal
visual weight so we just introduced some
mechanism of prioritizing or maybe we
don't need to show everything maybe we
can conceal a few things sometimes it's
just a matter of clarifying and this is
the paradoxical one in many cases
because to clarify often means we have
to add something sometimes
simplification happens with addition not
with subtraction and one of the best
examples is that icons alone always
perform more poorly than icons with
labels I have yet to see a study in
which labels do not help the
functionality of an icon and yet we seem
to be obsessed with crafting clever
little icons that have absolutely no
explanation and an abstract
representation of something really
important for people to do
wait why why have we made this
complicated right we did it because we
like pretty shiny so here are some
examples from Android will quickly run
through these over the past several
years the navigation bar those three
little icons at the bottom have changed
right
we first focused on simplifying the
visual representation and then we began
to consolidate functionality so in this
particular example here we have a tap
and a long press represented in that
graphic and then in the most recent
version this is all you get that little
pill down at the bottom is gestural
navigation was introduced so things have
been prioritized we've also moved the
search bar to the bottom so rather than
having interactive areas at the top and
at the bottom now all the inner core
interactivity is at the bottom of the
screen not only is it within thumb reach
on taller screens but it really doesn't
make sense to have two interaction zones
on the phone we changed the setup
journey so when you get a brand new
phone for the first time and it asks you
some information this journey actually
just has a few core actions that need to
happen but it looked like this at the
bottom and for some of the phone
manufacturers who inserted their own
steps into the setup process you might
actually go through 15 steps before you
can actually use your phone so we
started to say do you really have to do
all of it at the beginning can we maybe
delay some of this can we consolidate
some of these steps can we do it in a
different way and so the simplified
experience is basically down to the
three essential things that are
necessary to get your phone working and
then we say do you want to finish the
configuration now or would you like to
do it later and if someone says I want
to use my phone now I'll do the rest
later
sometime in the next seven days we send
them a little reminder hey there's still
a few things you need to do to keep your
phone or to get your phone set up and
keep it running would you like to do it
now and when they say yes we just drop
them into the remainder of the process
right so they can use their phone much
more quickly these are the volume
controls this was the old version where
when you open up the volume controls no
matter what you were doing you probably
saw ring and then all of the others and
then you had to figure out how do I
actually change the volume on my music
or my alarm
so we moved it and now the volume
controls actually show up on the screen
right next to where the little volume
rocker is on the side of the phone so we
changed the location proximity wise but
we also became smart about how the phone
was making sound at that moment and so
that would be the volume control that
you get when you use the rocker quick
settings was changed I'll show you this
is what it looks like visually so it's
much more clear that these are tapped
zones but the flow underneath was
radically changed each one of those
areas had to tap zones the icon in the
label were different and no one really
got that or understood that so now
there's just one tap zone but there's a
short tap and a long tap instead and
there's one fewer connections in there
as well notifications people the number
one complaint on any smart phone is the
number of notifications I'm being
bothered by my phone and so people often
don't know how do I stop these
notifications so now when you get a
notification and you dismiss it the
phone says do you not like this
notification you can turn it off and you
can do it right there in the
notification bar instead of going to
settings and we've just recently
introduced the digital well being
because people complain about being
interrupted by their phone and
distracted by the phone and spending too
much time on their phone and being
obsessed by their phone and being
worried about their phone and so they're
like well how long am i using my phone
every day and what am i doing on it and
where might I cut back so we gather all
of that data and we show it in a simple
graph and then you can dive in and you
can say how many times has this app
notified me how many times have I turned
on my phone and we make it very clear
what's happening and even watches the
watched for the the three core functions
when the phone when the the watch turns
on its your clock if you swipe from the
right it's your fitness and if you swipe
from the left its your calendar and
messages and notifications and any
assistant things all right so as we wrap
up talking about now we've got these
examples of simplicity the law of
complexity the law of conservation
complexity tells us that over time
complexity simply moves this is how
we've watched movies over the past you
know 70 years started with film and
projectors worked our way up through
Betamax and VCRs and DVDs and set-top
Roku's and little dongles that plug into
the back of your television right so it
seems like it should be a lot easier to
watch a movie today except now watching
the movie today requires your use of
three devices a television a dongle and
a mobile app right so the individual
device is simpler but the overall
experience has become complicated
because complexity moves as we address
it sometimes we need to use multiple
methods in multiple places right
experiences can paradoxically feel
simpler if you reduce the cognitive load
in the friction if you reduce ambiguity
if you help people feel more confident
in what they're doing even if it
actually takes more steps more time and
has more content right that's the
balance that we talked about earlier
meaningful focus Airport signage right
meaningful focus people feel like
they're doing something effectively if
they're making progress so as long as I
see the next sign I know where I'm going
value versus pain the value of the
outcome has to be greater than the cost
of the time and effort I'm not gonna do
it if it's gonna take too much time and
too much effort and we can turn this
into an equation the probability of
interaction is equal to the value of the
outcome divided by the effort put in to
achieving that outcome multiplied by my
confidence that this interaction is
going to get me what I need so you can
just think about calculating those three
things how what's the value how much
work and am i confident it's going to do
what I need this is an example of
sharing icons from 2012 I want to share
this picture hmm guess right because you
saw all these different icons you had no
idea what the tap on also a great
example of
unlabelled arbitrary illustrations I'm
not entirely sure why a gift is share
for Microsoft all right Anna caution
again simple metrics may not tell the
whole story
counting interactions is not a measure
of intent or purpose look how many times
they clicked on things because I have no
idea what I'm doing right the duration
of the interaction is not a measure of
engagement look how much time they spent
on our website because I'm completely
confused and can't figure out how to use
it or the task completion rate is not
always equivalent of easy and enjoyable
look how many people completed their
task yeah and I hated every second of it
right so just these measurements are
insufficient so the reminder feature
complete is not experience optimized and
when you find yourself at the top of
this curve remember that you have a set
of choices simplification isn't easy it
is possible there are things we can look
out for there are methods that we can
apply and we get to choose how far down
this side we're going to come all right
all right so thank you I know I went
over time sorry about that
they're up here they've been flashing
zero at me for like ten minutes thank
you I'll be around for the rest of the
time